eli is with us in Buffalo New York hi
Eli welcome to the Dave Ramsey show I am
the air you better than I deserve what's
up I'm a sophomore in high school and
right now I'm thinking of going to
college become an attorney and I was
wondering if you think seven years of
college and longer working
I don't think student loans are worth it
but I think law school is worth it and
so I would begin investigating ways to
go through law school without paying for
it with student loans finding other ways
to fund it and so forth so the question
is is it worth it so what what it costs
you versus what you would earn okay now
a law degree
generally speaking depending on what
type of law you go into doesn't matter
where you graduate from I have probably
six or seven lawyers that we pay money
to annually I can't tell you where any
of them went to school all I can tell
you about them is they're competent in
their particular area of practice
whether it's litigation or trademark
specialties one we have that we use we
have general counsel on staff I can't
even tell you where he graduated from
off the top of my head I think I know I
think you've grew into UT law but I'm
not positive he may be mad at me now
that I said that but we've got one
lawyer on staff and you know so the
point being as long as you learn the law
and the ability to practice law in a
particular area of law which is what
you're going to do you're going to end
up the law in most states you don't
specialize by you specialize practically
meaning you choose a type of law that
you want to practice you're going to do
criminal law or you can do civil
contests in court litigation of the
words or you can do real estate law or
are you going to do which is another guy
thinking of real estate do why now right
now I'm thinking your real estate okay
then what I would do is go talk to some
real estate people that are doing it and
ask them how what they make what do they
make and then look at what
cost so my point of my big discussion in
my blathering is this I would not pay a
bazillion dollars to go to law school
when you can go for a lot less than that
find a law school that's less expensive
and go get you an in-state degree from
an in-state school as cheaply as you
possibly can
and get a good high GPA work your butt
off so that you get accepted into law
school and then go to a may be a state
law school or or less but you don't have
to go to Harvard or Yale to be
successful in law you simply don't as a
matter of fact a lot of people don't go
to Harvard Yale they're very successful
now the last thing I'll tell you is this
any area of study any area of study the
number one correlation as to whether
you're successful whether it's medicine
law science teaching running a business
whatever your academic area of study is
where you went to school has almost zero
correlation to your success your
personal habits and character and
charisma to deal with people and your
perseverance your never-say-die attitude
your street smarts your common sense all
of those things have more to do with you
being successful than having a degree or
where you went to school now getting the
knowledge that you get while getting a
degree is very valuable so because
degrees are so expensive now Eli and
colleges are so expensive and there's
this huge backlash against all the
student loan debt and we've got all
these socialists like Bernie and so
forth telling people that they shouldn't
have to pay their student loan debt and
all that feel the Bern and all that crap
you know but all that stuff's going on
out there and so people are starting to
say college is not worth it
college is worth it so you asked me is
law school worthy yes law school is
worth it but it is not a Golden Willy
Wonka ticket
it does not make you successful to get a
degree and where you go to get the
degree does not make you successful you
Eli are your secret sauce the fact that
you're a singer is sophomore in high
school calling a show like this says
you've got the stuff you got the
gumption you got the grit you got the
ability to hustle and grind and in any
any career field if you don't have that
you sit around your hand stuck out going
nobody you have me that's because you're
freaking bomb with a degree that's why
nobody will hire you you're lazy
that's why nobody I'll hire you you walk
in with your pants around your knees to
do an interview that's why nobody will
hire you get a belt comb your hair take
a shower shake the man's hand the
woman's hand look them in the eye has
throw your shoulders back be somebody
that's how you get hired it's not like I
went to school so you deserve something
you're ain't entitled to nothing baby
and that's not to you Eli cuz you're the
guy we want to worry about being
entitled I mean who listens the Dave
Ramsey show in the sophomore in high
school wasn't me I can tell you that so
um you got a lot more on the ball than I
do so you're gonna be fine but guys the
thing is this
don't throw baby out with the bathwater
on education being ignorant as a
statement of socialism is a dumb idea
I'm not gonna go to school college isn't
worth it knowledge is worth it if it's
knowledge that's applicable in the
marketplace like a law degree it's worth
it I mean but there's no that there's
broke lawyers all over the place so you
actually have to learn how to run a
legal business if you learn how to get
clients and keep clients there's people
skills involved you know real estate
business you're gonna be dealing with
real estate people which are drama
queens I love them I am one and I've
been a real estate person all my life
but they're all high emotional you know
people and that's it so you're gonna be
dealing with in the real estate business
you're dealing with zoning boards and
bureaucrats with the law with the dadgum
city you know and all this stuff you're
gonna sue you're gonna be
with a very real estate attorney so if
you can't deal with all that you're
gonna be what's known as a broke real
estate attorney even though you got a
law degree it's not a golden Willy Wonka
ticket it is it's it gets your foot in
the door and then you still have to go
do the work folks so don't teach your
kids that education is a bad idea
education is a wonderful idea but don't
teach your kids that any education is
worth the money because it's not you get
a degree in German polka history it's
worthless you get a degree in gender
studies and then wonder why you can't
get a job
what's dumber than a rock of course
you're gonna have a problem with that
you know so think about what you're
doing they'll spent two hundred eighty
thousand dollars getting a master's
degree in social work that's a dumb idea
you know there's just not enough income
in that field to offset that expense
even if you didn't go in debt to do it
it doesn't make sense so you just have
to think through what are you spending
for what are you getting the little the
few pennies that I paid to get an
undergraduate degree in finance with
specialization in real estate the
University of Tennessee was worth a
bazillion times more than I paid for
it's worth every dime times a hundred
because I learned statistics I learned
finance I learned basic marketing skills
I learned accounting and I use all of
those things every day running this
business today some 40 years later I
even learned computer programming which
has absolutely nothing to do with
anything that is programmed today I can
promise you that you don't remember
those old punch cards yeah I had old
punch cards we sit in there with some
these ridiculous languages that that my
guys laugh about when I tell them that I
learned those languages but you know
what the critical thinking skills that
you use there are the same critical
thinking skills you do to program the
web today now I don't use them because I
don't do no I don't know how to do how
to write code but I suspect I could
probably learn it in about three weeks
if I didn't have anything else to do
because I've written code before getting
a degree I got a little taste of it and
so now when I'm dealing with people who
do that for me on my team now I'm ready
to do that so I Eli education is worth
as long as you go do something with your
life and don't wait on someone else to
bring you the water you're gonna be just
fine sir you're gonna be just fine pay
cash for it though pay cash for it's not
worth the student loan debt